bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de mickaël zeze bonjour michael kovacy
ensemble pour 45 minutes pour revoir et
commenter l'actualité de la semaine une
semaine sociale pour le gouvernement
jean marc ayrault annonce un plan de
lutte contre la pauvreté de 2 milliards
d'euros avec notamment une hausse du rsa
et puis en conseil des ministres c'est
la naissance des contrats de génération
dans l'entreprise promet ce numéro 33 du
candidat hollande florange toujours une
épine dans le pied du gouvernement héros
les syndicats claque la porte du comité
central d'entreprise de son côté lakshmi
mittal critiques dans la presse
française l'idée d'une nationalisation
dans cette émission nous irons à feu
rouge avec le sénateur pierre laurent
enfin nous reviendrons sur l'ump qui
s'enlise dans la crise de ses dirigeants
la cinquième rencontre n'a rien donné
mais on nous dit que les négociations
continuent les parlementaires ump rmp
sont appelés à voter mardi prochain pour
dire s'ils veulent d'une nouvelle
élection initiative déjà critiquée par
jean françois copé est avec nous pour
commenter toute cette actualité nous
accueillons marie noëlle lienemann
bonjour c'est sa triste socialiste de
paris
vous avez été à de nombreuses nombreuses
reprises ministre et puis vous êtes
aussi l'une des figures de l'ailé gauche
du parti socialiste on va y revenir bien
sûr dans cette émission vous ne
pratiquez pas la langue de bois est ça
aussi voulu le dire également pendant
notre émission je vous propose d'écouter
ce que pensent vos amis sénateurs
socialistes
un petit peu et dont nous allons bien
évidemment dans un instant vous pourrez
commenter écouter ils appliquent parfois
quelque chose qui t'a dit par che
guevera et qui consiste à déclarer
soyons réalistes exigeons l'impossible
se trouve ses limites dans la pratique
quotidienne et la politique mais j'ai
beaucoup de sympathie pour elle et en
même temps je suis persuadé que son
engagement est
et soutenir beaucoup de sel series et
marie noëlle lienemann et fortement
n'est certainement pas un caillou pour
le ps c'est pas non plus une forte tête
c'est quelqu'un qui a des convictions
chevillées au corps et qui les défend et
ça nous fait du bien parce que de temps
en temps il faut pouvoir entendre des
choses qui sont un peu iconoclaste moi
je l' ai connu à une époque rocardienne
social démocrate depuis elle a trouvé un
créneau sur lequel elle existe
intelligemment d'ailleurs pas seulement
dans la compassion mais aussi dans
l'affirmation est sûre c'est le propos
souvent intelligent mais pour moi peu
acceptable dans la mesure on peut pas
tous les jours demandé à exister à
travers un parti ac dont le parti est
dans le même temps se tenir aux franges
pour exister
lehmann à pied dedans un pied dehors cet
automne à la composition
je n'ai d'abord pas pour exister il ya
eu des périodes du coton n'existait pas
du tout personne ne s'intéressait à ce
qu'on disait quand on était contre la
montée du néolibéralisme le c'est gentil
de la part d'une partie de mes collègues
mais même de françois
mais moi justement c'est intéressant de
la remarque de françois patriat
oui moi j'étais social démocrate dans ce
qu'elles avaient de forces de soutien la
classe ouvrière dans les années 70 80
quand moi j'étais pour la cogestion à
l'allemande parce que je pensais qu'il
fallait que les ouvriers et les salariés
et des pouvoirs dans l'entreprise et et
quand j'ai vu que la social-démocratie
devenait social-libéral là je n'ai plus
été d'accord la social démocratie est un
compromis social le capital devait être
le travail devait être aussi bien
rémunérés voire mieux que le capital on
devait faire des progrès sociaux avec la
sécurité sociale on était dans une
société où on n'avait pas besoin de
l'affrontement permanent et qu'on
pouvait par la réforme
force est de constater qu'avec le
libéralisme la dureté de ce qu'on
appelait historiquement la lutte de
classe a et là se retrouver sa validité
mais plutôt au profit des patrons que du
monde ouvrier alors pourtant vous restez
au parti socialiste mais vous jouer ce
rôle de petite taille ou dans la nature
non pas du tout moi je suis au sein du
parti socialiste j'ai été dans la
majorité de françois hollande
je suis au sein du parti socialiste une
aile gauche donc cette aile gauche soit
la majorité du parti socialiste
considère qu'elle fait partie du pacte
qui permet d'avoir une majorité au sein
du parti
c'était le cas de martine aubry qui avec
qui on a très bien travaillé on a fait
très bon projet même si sur certains
sujets j'aurais préféré plus mais
c'était bien et puis on a des moments où
le parti socialiste ne veut pas
reconnaître son aile gauche
je rappelle à françois patriat que c'est
pas un caillou 25 28 % pour emmanuel
morel c'est pas un caillou 15% des
camarades qui votent pour la motion que
je défende est donc c'est trop facile de
nous dire vous êtes le petit grain de
sable le nom on est au coeur de la
question d'identité de la gauche
française et et de la question de est ce
que le parti socialiste se met au centre
de la gauche et pas au centre de
l'échiquier politique
donc là un gros caillou qui luttent de
l'intérieur on a bien compris on va
commencer
si vous voulez bien avoir ensemble
actualité de la semaine lundi
on commence avec le site de florange qui
reçoit la visite d'un sénateur
moins d'une semaine après l'accord entre
le gouvernement et mittal les salariés
ne désarment pas
les élus favorables à la nationalisation
sont venus les soutenir tout au long de
la semaine c'est le cas du sénateur
communiste pierre laurent que nous avons
suivi avec fabrice culine est regardée
l'occasion était trop belle pour pierre
laurent et le front de gauche de marquer
une nouvelle fois leur différence avec
le gouvernement à florange le secrétaire
national du parti communiste est venu
dénoncer l'accord signé avec
arcelormittal et soutenir les salariés
bien sûr qu'il ya autre chose à faire
j'ai j'ai dit au premier ministre au
sénat jeudi en l'interpellant qu'ils
fallaient réouvre
le dossier industriel la seule mise en
oeuvre des faibles engagements pris par
mittal pour le moment ne peut absolument
pas suffire et c'est ce qu'on va
discuter bien laurent est en terrain
conquis
ici l'accord laisse un goût amer la
nationalisation un temps évoquée par le
gouvernement avait créé de l'espoir dans
toute la vallée
l'attitude du gouvernement dans le très
mal me fait mal parce qu'il faut pas
prendre ça à la légère comme ça a été
fait toute une population col v ou qu'on
le veuille pas même si on l'y voit pas
tous les jours étaient tenus à cette
nationalisation de moi je considère que
quand mon amour a répondu à l'assemblée
nationale il y avait une forme
d'engagement avec cette première visite
depuis l'accord certains syndicats
craignent une récupération politique
mais de son côté la cgt accepte la main
tendue bah ça suffit pas à près d'un
autre côté faut bien commencer par
quelque chose vous savez on a pris un
coup phénoménal sur la tête vendredi en
pensant qu'on avait franchement gagné et
que du jour que deux heures après il ya
une contre-proposition les piqûres y
trouve un accord avec le groupe
arcelormittal maintenir la pression sur
le gouvernement au sénat comme sur le
terrain social
c'est la ligne politique du front de
gauche ces dernières semaines et ce
matin pierre laurent n'hésitait pas à
parler de fracture
moi je reste à côté des salariés ce
n'est pas moi qui n'ai fait qu'ils aient
fait un écart ou qu'ils aient créé une
fracture c'est le gouvernement qui s'est
mis à côté de l'engagement qu'il avait
pris
reste que la marge de manoeuvre du front
de gauche est étroite
une grande marche de solidarité est
envisagée en attendant l'intersyndicale
promet de durcir les actions sur le site
pour relever enfin ce qu'ils appellent
le flou autour de l'avenir de florange
alors dans la semaine les syndicats cgt
et fo ont claqué la porte du comité
d'entreprise
mais sur le fond les hauts fourneaux
sont des symboles mais économiquement
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
et que c'est un symbole qui est mort ça
commence à faire cher ce symbole n'est
pas du tout vous venez de voir le
rapport qui a été publié par la cfdt sur
les comptes de mittal l'entreprise la
plus rentable
c'est florence oui
au fond nous thyssen krupp il a on nous
dit assez haut pour nous ne sont pas
bien placés
thyssenkrupp l'essentiel de ces deux
séries ne sont pas au bord de la mer ils
sont en proximité des marchés émergents
l'étude de monsieur faure qui a été fait
par le demandé par le gouvernement
montrent que l'entreprise est viable
troisièmement on a un vrai sujet qui est
quel est l'avenir de la sidérurgie en
france
les vrais super bass et c'est le seul et
vrai les deux sont vraies parce qu'ils
sont liés
aujourd'hui nous sommes hyper dépendant
d'un mono acteurs que la multinationale
ni talent qui si pour des raisons
financières ne peut pas investir ou si
ce qui est le cas en réalité car elle
est hyper endetté tout le monde le sait
n'a pas d'argent pour mettre dans
l'investissement et c'est une des
raisons pour lequel ne se bousculent pas
pour le cos et deuxièmement si elle
décide d'aller ailleurs
nous nous sommes complètement que les
poings liés donc nous avons besoin de
reconstituer une stratégie de filière à
partir du moment et il n'y a aucune
raison que la que la sidérurgie parts de
lorraine alors qu'il ya au luxembourg
cna et c'est donc nous avons besoin de
reconstruire cette filière avec des
acteurs variés
là il y avait un repreneur là il y avait
le plan de montebourg et mes collègues
lorrain m'explique qu'ils ont vu ce plan
en tout cas les éléments de ce plan
qu'ils étaient fiables a dit qu'il n'y
avait jamais eu de on a jamais parlé
nationalisation lakshmi mittal dans une
interview au figaro du avec françois on
n'a jamais parlé de nationalisation ce
cas la raison tient toral je n'y crois
pas déjà donc des moyens entendu
françois hollande dire publiquement
qu'il y avait pas une nationalisation et
à ma connaissance
tel n'est pas le cas mais s'il le dit il
et il aura raison
simplement ce que j'observe c'est que
cette question' nationalisation était
portée par le ministre du redressement
productif que ce mini cela dit devant
l'assemblée nationale que c'était un bon
plan et donc moi je soutiens le plan
contenu est d'accord pour dire que
c'était une bonne idée
moi je ne suis pas d'accord sûr
d'accord on peut de nationaliser
aujourd'hui je rappelle que je l' ai
demandé d la rochelle la nationalisation
fusse-t-elle temporaire parce que
effectivement les nationalisations
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas celles d'hier
entendu monsieur mittal
c'était un bon en arrière ce qui disait
cette semaine en général devraient
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs
parce que monsieur mittal oublie qu aux
etats unis ils ont dans certains cas
nationalisées et même le grand journal
le monde on peut pas suspecter d'être
pro nationalisation vient de faire un
article dans les ananas ionisation des
usa ça marche mais n'y a pas que ça les
fonds souverains du qatar
c'est pas des fonds publics c'est pas
parce que ces limites que ça s'appelle
qatar c'est pas des fonds publics
c'est l'intérêt du qatar qui vont
décider les fonds souverains chinois les
chinois à le modèle chinois mais
regardez le nombre d'entreprises
publiques en chine ça traumatise
personnes pourquoi la france héritière
de colbert de 45 de de gaulle et
mitterrand serait incapable d'avoir une
gestion et une façon de faire ce qui
était bien prudent de la part d'arnaud
montebourg de dire d'un grand patron
kiki dont dépendent enfants des milliers
d'emplois qu'il devait partir comme ça
est-ce que ça va pas laisser des traces
à pamiers taux de cette formule moi j'ai
dit toujours avec le patronat il faut
avoir la force tranquille des certitudes
de ce qu'on défend
moi je ne suis pas force tranquille
sexuellement n'était pas pour dire aussi
vital doit quitter la france
j'étais pour dire monsieur mittal n'est
pas le maître de la politique c'est des
logiques française et donc si monsieur
mittal quitte la lorraine
s'il ne fait pas des bons choix pour
l'avenir la sidérurgie française et ben
l'état interviendra il veut fermer les
hauts fourneaux nous l'empêcherons de le
faire nous cherchons une stratégie
alternative pour le reste vous y croyez
encore mal malgré là quand je demande au
gouvernement de réouvrir le dossier
vous pensez que parce que l'initiale
mais oui parce que là les le parti
socialiste quand il a appris en battant
des mais justement pour renationaliser
pourquoi qu'est ce que je dis le parti
ce salon métrage qui a été fait par jean
marc laimé à l'époque où nous avons dû
clés aux fourneaux allait continuer à
l'époque où nous avons dû yahia quand j
à l'épaule il ya peu de temps que le
programme houle cos allaient pouvoir se
mettre en oeuvre on est dans le bourg
car le plus complet on nous dit que les
hauts fourneaux vont être fermées même
le compte le comité du ps dans son texte
écrit qu'il fallait que les hauts
fourneaux reste ouvert pour reprendre
on va passer au mardi avec un premier
ministre très attendu sur la pauvreté
c'est jean marc ayrault qui clôt la
conférence nationale sur la pauvreté qui
se tient à paris discours très attendu
par les associations qui rappelle le
chiffre de neuf millions de personnes
qui en france vivent en dessous du seuil
de la pauvreté
le premier ministre a surtout annoncé
l'amélioration de dispositifs déjà
existants explications de marion
lefebvre elle l'équation était
compliquée proposé un pacte de
solidarité sans plomber les caisses de
l'état déjà vides et dans ce contexte
difficile et face à son impopularité et
jean marc ayrault devait donner des
gages aux associations j'ai décidé de
redresser la courbe de progression du
rsa socle pour amener son niveau à 50 %
du smic
je souhaite que d'ici 2017
c'est à dire la fin du quinquennat il
est augmenté de 10% en plus de
l'indexation annuelle sur l'inflation
avec une première revalorisation dès
septembre 2013
près de 1,4 million de français
devraient en bénéficier est la mesure
coûtera 1 milliard d'euros en 2017
parmi les autres annonces une réforme du
rsa activité et de la prime pour
l'emploi dès l'année prochaine
la création d'une allocation de 450
euros pour les jeunes en difficulté qui
s'engagent dans un parcours de retour
vers l'emploi mais aussi la
revalorisation du plafond de ressources
de la cmu
cinq cent mille personnes devraient
accéder au dispositif 8000 places
d'urgence supplémentaires seront créés
pour les sans abri et une garantie des
risques locatifs devraient aider
l'ensemble des locataires des annonces
saluées par les associations présentes
un premier pas pour elle il faut aller
bien plus loin on parle vous savez
beaucoup d'état providence c'est un peu
d'états et beaucoup
deux choses qui repose sur la providence
bon bah là on a quand même des mesures
concrètes le point de satisfaction c'est
de voir que sur le rsa il ya des choses
concrètes qui sont posées c'est pas la
hauteur ce que nous espérions puisque
nous espérions une revalorisation plus
rapide pour faire face à cette pauvreté
à la précarité
jean marc ayrault a également annoncé la
mise en place d'un comité
interministériel de lutte contre
l'exclusion
my noëlle lienemann légère hausse du rsa
extension la cmu dispositif pour les
jeunes aile gauche que vous représentez
du parti est elle plutôt satisfaites
dans chez un vrai pas en avant un délai
des mesures concrètes utile évidemment
dans un cadre concret contre 1 qu'elle
le cadre économique on a retenu du 3% de
déficit et c est moi je pense qu'on ne
peut pas séparer la lutte contre la
pauvreté de tout ce qu'on a dit sur
emploi leur revalorisation salariale
parce qu'il faudrait pas non plus avoir
donné le sentiment on laisse dériver
d'un côté et on essaie de colmater la
brèche de l'autre jeu aux travailleurs
pauvres aujourd'hui voilà énormément et
pour moi c'est une question centrale
j'espère surtout que les annonces pour
rentrer dans les faits parce que il ya
souvent beaucoup d'inertie c'est
compliqué je pensais à l'hébergement
d'urgence
il faut absolument qu'on arrive à avoir
les crédits pour sortir les gens de
l'urgence dans le logement social et
j'en profite pour dire il faudrait que
la tva du logement social repasse à 5
vitesse grand v pour qu'on fasse les
cent cinquante mille logements ce qui
permettra d'améliorer l'accès au
logement pour tous alors passez au
toujours mardi à l'assemblée nationale
on a voté le projet de budget
rectificatif pour 2012 ce budget intègre
notamment la création du crédit d'impôt
pour la compétitivité le prêt de 20
milliards d'euros qui sera financée en
partie par des hausses de tva l'on sait
que l'ump et le front de gauche ont voté
contre n'imagine noëlle lienemann que ce
plan de compétitivité c'est pas
forcément votre tasse de thé non c'est
pas ma tasse de thé
et j'espère me tromper j'espère que les
femmes donneront tort mais je crains que
ça ne marche pas 20 milliards de cadeaux
aux entreprises fondées sur la masse
salariale la moitié n'ira pas aux
entreprises qui sont confrontées à la
con à la à l'industrie ou à la
compétitivité mondiale
je prends un exemple les cliniques
privées vont pouvoir bénéficier
j'ai rien contre elle mais vont
bénéficier du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité et comme pour financer ce
crédit d'impôt compétitivité on va d'une
part augmenter la tva d'autre part
réduire de 10 milliards en plus de ce
qui était déjà prévu les dépenses
publiques
eh bien on va serrer la vis des hôpitaux
publics en dix ans les cas sensibles ou
pas oui déjà
si on concentraient les aides moi je ne
suis pas hostile à ce qu'on est des
entreprises qui sont dans la compétition
mondiale qui sont pour pour redémarrer
l'investissement industriel
oui je considère qu'il faut tout mettre
de notre côté pour que notre industrie
redémarrer se développe donc il y en a
déjà la moitié qui sert à rien et ça
c'est pas moi qui le dit monsieur
gallois et même les dispositifs sont
moins favorable à l'entreprise que ce
que demandait gallois dans son calcul
donc moi je dis déjà c'est une mauvaise
méthode deux mondes disait social
démocrate mais oui je suis social
démocrate l'a fait qu'elle négocie le
libéralisme alors c'est ça oui je
m'excuse de dire que c'est classiquement
ce que la droite nous dit depuis des
années besson le coût du travail
mettons des aides fiscales etc et ça
marche pas si ça marchait je me dirais
bon pas de souci - c'est pas juste non
moi ça marche mais ça marche pas
pourquoi ça marche pas parce que
pourquoi ils ont fait ça si vite parce
que les espagnols ont baissé de 15 20 à
30 % les salaires dans les politiques
d'austérité et qu'on se dit à six parce
que on fait semblant d'être en
concurrence et que les allemands n'ont
le choix qui est fait c'est d'éviter que
sa partenaire liman donc on va suivre
et moi j'ai dit tant que l'europe n'aura
pas un smic des convergences sur les
salaires pour que les écarts ne soit pas
du dumping social
eh ben on sera en course en arrière faut
faire autre chose à vue et à d'autres
pour les tirer sans doute vu là une des
hebdomadaires cette semaine
dans le nouvel observateur hollande le
désaveu ou encore marianne mon
adversaire c'est la finance dix sept
îles vous êtes d'accord
ce plfr par exemple ce crédit d'impôt
sur les entreprises à tout ça ça fait
partie comme ça d'une déception je pense
d'une a compris la campagne voilà moi je
j'observe qu'il ya des choses qui
étaient dans les 60 propositions de
françois hollande qui sont pas faites
bon je prends un exemple qui elle est
l'interdiction des licenciements fall
l'encadrement des licenciements
boursiers ou bien les l'idée de la
reprise obligatoire quand une usine
ferme
ça s'est pas fait par contre on a dit
pendant toute la campagne
connais tu es contre la hausse de la tva
parce que ça a plombé le pouvoir d'achat
ex allait freiner la croissance et ont
fait une hausse de la tva nous laver
pendant toute la constituant pas des
deux entreprises sans contrepartie il ya
même des za businness que si encore cela
est ce que c'est pour cela que vous avez
réuni cette semaine
l'ensemble de la gauche de la gauche
c'est à dire les verts yve les
participants du front de gauche et vous
même l'or au musée social à paris c'est
quoi c'est un contre gouvernement que
vous voulez mettre en place
non c'est pas pour cela legault le club
gauche avenir il existe depuis six ans
est en terre depuis la précédente
présidentielle avec un axe stratégique
était simple c'est la gauche ne fait
rien de bias il n'est pas rassemblé ni
pour gagner ni pour transformer la
société
donc notre objectif c'est le
rassemblement de la gauche la deuxième
le deuxième objectif c'est que nous on
est fier d'être de gauche et nous
pensons que la gauche on est au rendez
vous d'aujourd'hui c'est même une piste
d'avenir
donc on voulait vraiment unique donc
nous nous disons c'est une mauvais signe
que la gauche soit pas capable de se
rassembler dans le gouvernement mais
plus encore à l'assemblée et au sénat
donc nous nous faisons ce rassemblement
pour que des convergences puisse
apparaître
et il est vrai que ça veut dire à ce
moment là qu'il faut avoir une majorité
alternative à ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
qui est très restreint dans un espace
pour préparer l'avenir
donc nous préparons l'avenir et nous
nous nos thèmes à nous c'est à nouveau
front populaire rassembler toutes les
forces de gauche autour de nouveaux
progrès collectif alors il ya un député
socialiste cette semaine qui aurait été
acclamé sûrement dans votre club
il s'appelle yann galut et pour pour
faire peur
exilés fiscaux il propose de retirer de
leur retirer la nationalité française
cette idée lui est venue bien sûr quand
il a appris que gérard depardieu avait
cédé aux charmes d'une petite bourgade
belge bourgade belge on écoute le député
qui était très entourée par les
journalistes en ce mardi aux quatre
colonnes on demande des efforts à tous
les français on va demander des efforts
aux entreprises on va demander des
efforts aux particuliers et on a
quelqu'un qui comme ça nous annoncent
qu'ils quittent la france pour aller
s'installer en belgique pour payer moins
d'impôts donc moi je pose la question
j'ouvre le débat il y à d'autres
législations il ya d'autres pays où vous
devez payer la différence entre ce que
vous payez dans votre pays et le pays
d'accueil
et bien moi je considère que gérard
depardieu comme d'autres exilés fiscaux
doivent payer le différentiel d'impôts
et s'il ne paye pas ce différentiel
d'impôts on doit leur poser la question
doivent-ils encore rester français
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être français
aujourd'hui
yann galut qui a eu tellement de succès
que sa proposition qui va présider un
groupe de travail au sein du groupe ps à
l'assemblée
bonne piste pour vous il avait sauté
exactement ce que ceux dont on parle
yann c'est pas d'enlever la nationalité
c'est de faire comme aux états unis
tout citoyen français qui paient qui
iron qui résident ailleurs payent les
impôts là où il réside et le
différentiel avec ce qu'ils paieraient
en france en france et alors on a fait
rapport au sénat
donc nos collègues vont pouvoir s'en
inspirer et dans ce rapport au sénat on
nous a expliqué que la difficulté
provenait du fait que c'était assez long
parce qu'il fallait renégocier toutes
nos conventions fiscales donc moi je
propose qu'on te fasse très vite cette
loi et qu'on commence une première
négociation que la belgique car je ne
crois pas que les belges soit très
satisfaits d'avoir cette image de
paradis fiscal
ce n'est pas célèbre jeu donne cet
exemple parce que c'est là qu'on a le
plus exilés les plus proches
vous comprenez je suis ton cerveau
depardieu misérable comme le dit jean
marc ayrault no comments est tellement
faim ne sait pas lui quelle vie minable
je les recettes et encore oui bon bah
oui misérables c'est beaucoup plus on me
l'a personnellement non c'est pas chacun
ses mots c'est consternant
qu'est-ce que franchement mais tout
l'argent qu'il aille en fait quoi
mais il a pas l'air en plus il n'a pas
l'air d'être pétillants de bonheur en
étant obligé de boire
franchement lens
vraiment changer de sujet est-ce que
vous suivez un petit peu le feuilleton
de l'ump j'ai abandonné
pourtant vous allez savoir que mardi
prochain
eh bien les parlementaires sénateurs et
députés vont voter à l'assemblée
nationale à l'initiative de bernard
accoyer référendum pour savoir s'il faut
voter ou pas les explications de jérôme
andrieu
cette fois l'idée est signée bernard
acoyer un référendum pour tout les
parlementaires ump
l'objectif reste identique sortie à
l'opposition la crise tous ont rendez
vous mardi prochain
nous nous exprimons à bulletins secrets
pour ou contre de nouvelles élections de
la part de tous nos militants pour
désigner le nouveau président de l'ump
avant l'été 2013
une fois le calendrier fixé françois
fillon devrait abandonner son groupe à
l'assemblée
et tout recours juridique la proposition
séduit les non alignés et les
fillonnistes que les parlementaires se
mobilisent comme on a essayé de le faire
de l'organiser avec bruno le maire comme
bernard accoyer le propose aujourd'hui
avec un vote des parlementaires pour
dire qu'ils souhaitent re voter c'est
une bonne chose aussi tout ce qui peut
nous aider à aller vers ce nouveau vote
qui moi je crois est la seule issue est
une bonne chose si les parlementaires
dans son département
affirme collégialement et une forte
majorité qu'il faut aller vers une
burgod vois pas comment jean françois
copé - pourtant l'équation n'est pas si
simple pour les copéiste cette
initiative n'a tout simplement aucune
légitimité
les parlementaires sont élus pour
représenter le peuple dans les
institutions donc à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat et n'ont rien à voir
avec les problèmes partisans thomas
allier il passe la ligne
moi je pense que c'est une erreur c'est
une proposition que sa part mais je
pense que c'est une erreur
chaque cheval en bois sont l'aude
initiative voilà les uns et les autres
peuvent avoir envie d'exister un moment
mais la responsabilité
le mouvement c'est entre le fillon et
copé et je leur fais confiance à tous
les jean françois copé et françois
fillon n'ont pas rompu le dialogue ils
se sont rencontrés pour la cinquième
fois ce soir pour éviter tout blocage
définitif
alors même si vous n'êtes peut-être un
petit peu comme ça vous a permis aussi
de revoir un peu ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine le fait que les
parlementaires reprennent comme ça le
mouvement qui vous pensez que ça peut
faire changer les choses c'est un coup
de pression je n'arrive pas à être
passionné par cette affaire les
parlementaires sont aptes à régler la
crise de leur parti en fait d'une
manière générale en tout cas pour le
milieu de partie
je ne pense que ce n'est pas le groupe
parlementaire qui doit se substituer aux
instances du parti
c'est une tentation notamment quand on
est au pouvoir de d2 ne plus donner aux
militants aux cadres politiques leurs
responsabilités et puisqu'on parlait
tout à l'heure de la gauche
moi ce que je souhaitais que je demande
depuis longtemps c'est qu'il ya comité
de liaison permanent des partis de
gauche parce que il ya du travail à
faire sur le terrain politique et pas
simplement sur le terrain législatif ou
gouvernemental alors passer au mercredi
avec l'acte de naissance du contrat de
génération
c'est donc la promesse numéro 33 de
françois hollande qui arrive en conseil
des ministres le contrat de génération
prévoit un débit nos jeunes et seniors à
contrepartie d'allègements de charges
pour les entreprises les détails et les
explications avec elisa berthelot mais
c'est la 33e promesse de campagne de
françois hollande le contrat de
génération adopté ce matin en conseil
des ministres le texte a été présenté
cet après midi en commission des
affaires sociales un contrat avec un
objectif très clair plutôt que d'opposer
une politique en faveur des jeunes qui
aurait des effets négatifs sur les
seniors ou une politique en faveur des
seniors qui aurait des effets négatifs
pour l'accueil des jeunes
il est proposé de réconcilier d'unifier
faire en sorte qu'il y ait
ce pacte entre les générations le
principe concerne les entreprises de
moins de 300 salariés pour chaque jeune
de moins de 26 ans recruté et chaque
maintien de seniors de plus de 57 ans
l'entreprise a droit à un allègement de
charges de 4000 euros par an une aide
qui durera jusqu'à trois ans pour le
contrat jeunes pour le senior elle
pourra être étendue jusqu'à son départ à
la retraite
en revanche les entreprises de plus de
300 salariés ne toucheront pas dette de
l'état mais auront l'obligation de
mettre en place ce type de contrat sous
peine de pénalités financières
à terme le gouvernement prévoit la mise
en place de cinq cent mille contrats par
an le coût global de ce contrat de
génération lorsqu'il sera temps en
application pleine et entière dans trois
à quatre ans sera de l'ordre 900
millions à un milliard
le gouvernement dès le début a considéré
que c'était une des dispositions du
pacte de compétitivité
questionné sur le financement michel
sapin reste volontairement imprécis le
texte sera discuté en séance début
janvier 2013
marie noëlle lienemann un mot sur
l'esprit de ce projet un lavage c'est le
jeune très pur c'est très bien mais il
ya des tas de choses a donc publique
d'investissement je suis très tout non
non c'est une très belle fille de le
savoir
c'est une très belle idée parce que je
crois catégories de population qui sont
très touché un point bas et puis surtout
parce que je pense qu'on a à renouer le
pacte générationnel ça j'y crois
beaucoup
y en a marre de poser d un réseau qui a
des savoir faire accumulé qu'il faut
transmettre parfait je suggère puisqu'on
cherche le milliard que je vis recherche
de merzhin que le gouvernement sait
aussi où le trouver le jeu je suggère
que dans les conditionnalités puisqu'on
a fait ce crédit d'impôt compétitivité
et ben moi je suis pour vous mettre des
conditions et on pourrait très bien
considéré que pour les grandes
entreprises
eh ben la condition c'est que tout pour
eux par exemple x % de leurs salariés
ayant plus de 55 ans il ya x % dans des
emplois d'avenir qu'ils soient
obligatoirement si je puis dire
déclenchée en entreprise ça n'enlèverait
pas le dispositif
vous voyez que cette conditionnalité
aurait en effet 20 milliards d'un côté
un milliard de l'eau ne vais pas me dire
qu'on peut pas un plus
trois questions à mme lienemann relayent
au parler du plan de pauvreté tout à
l'heure qui coûterait entre 2 milliard
et deux milliards et demi sur cinq ans
la c 1 milliard également qu'il faut
trouver où est ce qu'on trouve cet
argent alors qu'on doit faire des
économies
justement je pense que sur cela mais on
pourrait peut-être jouer sur ce milliard
de compétitivité ce 20 milliards de
conclure bill haugland compétitivité les
comédiens qui sont un corbillard qui
sont et puis il ya effectivement dans
certains sujets à orienter les crédits
classiques plutôt vers les plus démunis
et vers ceux qui sont le lot plus en bas
de l'échelle
il n'a pas dit que c'était 2 milliard de
dépenses en plus dans le budget c'était
dans l'ensemble des dépenses budgétaires
de l'état arrivé à l'est ciblées vers
les populations j'entendais ce que de
l'autre côté on dit c'est de
l'assistanat
non mais ça c'est non je suis pas du
tout d'accord c'est pas de l'assistanat
c'est de permettre aux gens de rebondir
c'est le tout contre l'assistanat c'est
ne pas installer durablement les gens à
s'ancrer dans l'incapacité à retrouver
pleinement leur autonomie leur place
dans la société
et cet exemple à sa très belle exempt
comme les emplois dans tremplin j'ai
plus de non emploi tremplin femmes en
tous cas les jeunes qui ont va permettre
de à qui on va permettre j'étais hier je
vous donne un exemple j'avais un
problème de voiture je rentre dans une
station service vers orly dont j'ai été
maire pendant longtemps de la commune
d'à côté est la personne qui tenait la
station-service me dit madame je suis
contente j'ai été votre premier emploi
jeune quand vous étiez maire eh ben ça
m'a fait plaisir parce que ce dispositif
il avait bien marché et m'a expliqué
qu'elle avait évité lui avait évité des
dérives excellent l'avait remis sur le
bon chemin
on va parler d'un de vos collègues le
sénateur jean-noël guérini qui connaît
quelques surprises s'est fait sans
surprise le sénat a décidé d'accéder à
la demande du juge marseillais chargé de
l'enquêté judiciaire et de lever
l'immunité de ce sénateur le détail avec
sophie normand
c'est la deuxième fois que l'immunité
parlementaire de jean noël guérini élevé
le bureau du sénat dit ainsi oui à la
demande du juge d'instruction
objectif pour l'injustice placé en garde
à vue le sénateur socialiste pour
l'interroger sur un autre volet du
dossier de marchés publics présumés
frauduleux dans lequel il est mis en
examen depuis septembre 2011
le bureau a apprécié décision qui était
qui n'est pas une surprise pour personne
il va pouvoir se justifier encore
beaucoup plus élevés par rapport à ceux
qui lui est ce qui a justifié cette
levée c'est la meilleure façon pour lui
de d'avoir à présenter sa défense
selon le juge d'instruction il
existerait une ou plusieurs raisons
plausibles de soupçonner le président du
conseil général des bouches-du-rhône
d'avoir commis les délits de corruption
passive trafic d'influencé association
de malfaiteurs le rôle de jean noël
guérini est difficile à cerner mais il
aurait assuré de façon systématique le
succès des entreprises de son frère et
de ses amis par ses interventions
influente ses actions ses abstentions
le sénateur marseillais a assuré qu'il
souhaitait cette décision pour
s'expliquer dans les délais les plus
brefs
sa levée d'immunité parlementaire
intervient au lendemain de la mise en
examen du sénateur de l'hérault robert
navarro pour abus de confiance à
l'époque où il dirigeait la fédération
socialiste du département
son immunité avait été levé en mars
j'imagine que vous avez une pièce normal
de lever sensibilité c'est une bonne
chose
par contre je voudrais un petit peu plus
loin sur le parti socialiste on sait
qu'il ya eu plusieurs missions qu'on
était lancée à l'époque par un autre
sénateur alain richard pour aller voir
sur les fédérations du parti socialiste
que ce soit dans les bouches du rhône
que ce soit dans le nord de la france
est ce que le ménage a été fait au parti
socialiste il ya beaucoup de progrès en
tout cas moi j'ai beaucoup suivi ce qui
s'est passé en particulier dans la
fédération des bouches du rhône pour le
vote au congrès parce qu'inutile de vous
dire que les minorités en général
n'était pas très très bien traité dans
ces grosses minutes dans ces grosses
fédérations
très franchement constaté l'an nous est
importante à décoller que les militants
réellement voté qu' il y avait eu
beaucoup de les listes avaient été
énormément
comment dire et ajusté à la baisse donc
plutôt dans plus tôt pour éviter qu'ils
aient des confusions des fausses cartes
d'ailleurs je ne dis pas qu'il n'y ait
pas ici ou là mais honnêtement nous
n'avons pas eu de repos roche alors
qu'on était très présent dans dix
sections
on a eu tout n'a pas fait de remarques
sur les dysfonctionnements majeurs de
cette fédération bourg d'ailleurs qu'il
y avait pendant les primaires là le
problème d'un genou et avancer des
choses c'est toujours sur ces sujets là
toujours très délicat parce qu'on a des
présomptions et on n'a pas toujours les
faits mais les preuves et c'est toujours
très ambigu de commencer à fonctionner
sur des rumeurs mais alors voilà sur la
fédération des bouches du rhône nous
avions soutenu et dr martine aubry avait
diligenté une enquête
comme d'ailleurs sur la faune sur la
fédération libéraux de l'hérault la
fédération du pas-de-calais toujours
sous le sous un contrôle de la du
national donc l'avait bien engagée
j'avais progrès travail de voix là et je
pense qu'il faut être d'une grande
vigilance collective et je pense qu'on
est sur le bon chemin
elle va passer au jeudi petite confusion
retour du mariage pour tous comme tous
les jeudis la commission des lois mène
ces auditions sur le mariage pour tous
un peu perplexe ce jour là sur la
position du gouvernement concernant la
procréation médicalement assistée
christiane taubira à la ministre se
serait prononcé pour françois hollande
rappelle qu'il ne l'a pas prévu dans ses
promesses de campagne
petite confusion au sommet de l'état
c'est un sujet de betty la guerre
jusqu'à présent la pma la procréation
médicalement assistée
le gouvernement n'en voulait pas mais
depuis deux jours les lignes bougent de
façon quelque peu confuse
christiane taubira aurait d'abord abordé
le sujet mardi lors d'un colloque sur la
laïcité propos démentis par l'intéressé
qui affirme qu'elle parlait d'adoption
et non de pma pourtant des lendemains la
porte parole du gouvernement
rebondissait sur ses propos ça signifie
si on en croit ce qu'est ce qu'elle a
dit mais je c'est ainsi que je ressens
aussi les choses en effet que le
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
bloquer à tout prix cette mesure
et hier soir c'était au tour du
président de la république pourtant
personnellement opposé à cette mesure de
lâcher du lest à ce stade
j'ai considéré que c'était le mariage et
l'adoption
et si le parlement et je crois que il y
aura des propositions d'amendements
décide d'aller dans le sens de la
procréation médicale assistée
le parlement est souverain à gauche
certains députés socialistes espèrent en
effet aller plus loin que la promesse
présidentielle nous sommes nombreux à
penser dans sein du groupe socialiste et
le parti socialiste n'est encore
confirmé qu'au contraire c'est le bon
moment pour aussi discuter de ce sujet
et que c'est justement opportun est
nécessaire de l'inclure dans ce projet
doit bruno le roux lui même patron des
députés ps entend déposer un amendement
pour que la pma figure dans le projet de
loi
le groupe se réunira mercredi prochain
pour discuter notamment de son champ
d'application
marie noëlle lienemann c'est une
question importante est ce que sur un
tel sujet de société
le gouvernement et le président lui-même
ne doivent pas avoir une copie un peu
moins brouillonne à présenter au
parlement
non la copie n'est pas brouillonne
puisqu'il n'ya pas de l'anti peu de mal
à voir quelle est l'intention du goût du
gouvernement et du président sur les
questions lgbt tout a été dit ils ne
vont pas revenir sur le choix initial
qui avait été fait de ne pas mettre la
peu dans le texte gouvernemental
la procréation médicalement assistée
avec une thèse qui était historiquement
celle de françois hollande qui est de
dire on verra
ultérieurement comment évolue c'est à
fait surtout laisse le parlement
désormais se cache un petit peu vers
l'est par le moteur non mais attendez
j'espère bien qu'on laisse le parlement
décide et non mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire la ceca normal s'il
est au final mais on peut présenter une
sur lesquels on est sur lequel on est on
sait ce qu'il a dit il a dit moi
personnellement le gouvernement ne
dépose
évidemment pour le gouvernement ne fera
pas la proposition s'il va assembler les
parlements de le faire président du
groupe socialiste en personne qui va
déposer la proposition sur la paix
madiot mais oui mais non mais attendez
sur des sujets comme ça c'est
extrêmement important que le parlement
puisse faire son travail d'ailleurs moi
personnellement je pense que sur
beaucoup de sujets devraient le faire je
trouve que l'idée de dire que le
parlement n'est pas là pour essayer de
parfois même changé assez fortement
je vous prends l'exemple on était tout à
l'heure sur le crédit compétitivité
mettre des conditions à ce crédit
pourquoi le parlement n'auraient pas la
possibilité de faire ça c'est pas je
veux voir qu'une seule tête sur ce texte
cela il y aura probablement il y aura le
dépôt de de bruno le roux jeu pensions
ce sera laquelle mondialement je suis
d'accord avec le gouvernement
la procréation médicale assistée
je suis pas content je m'interroge
personnellement beaucoup à titre
personnel je m'interroge beaucoup je
n'engage que moi là je pense qu on est
chacun devancé les choisit le personnel
est je pense plus prudent et plus
conforme à ce que je ressens le fait
d'attendre ni une étape ultérieure pour
voir comment évoluent les choses
en revanche je considère qu'aujourd'hui
il faut qu'on soit bien bien au clair
sur l'adoption
il me semble tout à fait normal qu'à
partir du moment où des couples sont
mariés ils puissent adopter ensemble un
enfant et en partager la la parentalité
au sénat le groupe socialiste est très
partagée que ce soit l'assemblée et au
sénat
j'en sais rien quand il n'y a pas entre
vous encore à ses côtés jusqu'au bout on
n'a pas eu de débat collectif on a on a
des débats
enfin en déjeunant et où je sais que par
exemple michel andré est quelqu'un qui
est très favorable la pma et elle elle
va la défendre avec force aux qui aura
aussi le bout de débat on imagine ansa
au sein des groupes parlementaires va
parler d'un autre sujet car l'oublient
pas que vous avez été également députée
européenne et l'europe considèrent cette
avancée comme historique accord à
l'arraché
après des heures de négociations l'union
bancaire va voir le jour
en somme les banques nationales seront
supervisés au niveau européen l'objectif
est très clair éviter les crises et
leurs comptes agents toutes les
explications de kathia gilder une fois
n'est pas coutume les bonnes nouvelles
se sont succédé à bruxelles quelques
heures avant l'ouverture du conseil
les dirigeants européens ont conclu deux
accords majeurs ils ont donné le feu
vert au mécanisme de supervision
bancaire et accepté de débloquer une
nouvelle aide à la grèce
34 3 milliards d'euros satisfaction
générale
c'est une bonne journée pour l'europe
depuis le sommet de la fin du mois de
juin nous avons avancé et nous avons pu
régler cette nous-mêmes et la question
de la grèce qui faisait débat depuis
tant de mois et la question de l'union
bancaire puisque la crise est venue des
banques et que les mécanismes ont été
introduits pour que plus rien ne soit
plus comme avant
désormais les banques les plus
importantes de la zone euro seront
placées sous le contrôle d'un gendarme
unique la banque centrale européenne les
établissements en difficulté pourront
être recapitalisées directement sans que
les états paye
objectif éviter les crises bancaires et
surtout leur contagion la grande
bretagne a choisi de rester en dehors de
cette union comme la suède et la
république tchèque
mais l'europe a fait un pas vers
l'intégration nous avons commencé la
semaine avec le prix nobel reçu à oslo
terminons la avec un bon résultat
l'union bancaire ne sera pas
opérationnel avant mars 2014
d'ici là les dirigeants auront le temps
de se pencher sur l'autre gros dossier
la gouvernance économique avec l'espoir
d'en finir avec la crise ben lienemann
c'est pour vous un bon accord historique
un grand pas historique n'exagérons pas
à toute façon dès qu'il s'agit de sauver
les banques
croyez-moi leur part yves toujours à se
mettre d'accord cela dit c'est positif
c'est positif et une super mission c'est
pas un contrôle c'est la supervision
européenne mais mais en revanche il ya
plusieurs choses qui ne sont pas traités
qui sont très alarmantes
parce que superviser avec quels
objectifs premièrement nous avons
accepté le système bâle iii ça peut
paraître très technique mais c'est un
système qui
mais il est très important car c'est
celui qui réduit les capacités de crédit
les etats unis ont refusé pour justement
soutenir leur croissance et ne pas avoir
des conditions qui brident le crédit
c'est pour ça que les anglais refuse
également au sinon les anglais toute
façon c'est leur histoire brille comme
un pas important dans l'intégration
politique mais comme par hasard on
n'était que pour les banques et la
finance
et on ne fait absolument rien où ils
sont le pacte de croissance
les 120 milliards là on aurait aimé que
ce conseil ait aussi sur sa relation
bancaire pour en venir
il n'y a pas de sanction prévue un
samedi bien sûr bon en même temps à
partir du moment où les banques
on alerte il ya une sanction d'opinion
qui est assez forte sur les marchés
ça se sait vite et la dernière chose je
ne voudrais pas que cette supervision
bancaire en baie empêche les bancs
publics d'avoir des stratégies qui sont
un peu décalée des règles habituelles du
marché notamment en risque prudentielles
marino les macbooks de respectant pierre
moscovici dit nous sortons de la crise
de la zone euro
françois hollande également et pour vous
écouter j'espère qu'il ne se trompe pas
je voudrais qu'il m'en fasse un peu plus
la preuve et pour sortir de la zone euro
faut arrêter l'austérité dans l'est qui
frappe les peuples parce qu'il faudrait
pas que l'euro soit sauvé et que
l'europe soit complètement out parce que
l'emploi y aurait disparu l'industrie
aussi et c'est donc pour moi il n'y a
pas de bonnes nouvelles tant qu'on n'a
pas une stratégie de croissance qui se
met en oeuvre et tant qu'on n'arrête pas
l'austérité pour renouer avec un certain
nombre de convergences sociale vers le
haut marie noëlle lienemann c'est sur
ces mots que nous allons nous quitte et
merci d'avoir été avec nous tout au long
de cette émission du lundi au jeudi ou
vendredi à la semaine prochaine à la
semaine prochaine